[موسيقى]
الى هنا وصلوا ومن هنا مروا وهذا ما فعلوا
هذه عدن جنوبي
اليمن اما تعز فلم يكتفوا بقصف
احيائها بل فرضوا عليها حصارا
[موسيقى]
خانقا الحدي
على ساحل البحر الاحمر سقطت في
ايديهم اجتياح مسلح تهاوت امامه اهم المدن
اليمنيه الحوثيون القادمون من شمال الشمال
ما سر قوه هؤلاء وما هي العوامل التي
مكنتهم من كل هذا وكيف حيكت خيوط
[موسيقى]
اللعبه الايقاع السريع للاحداث لم يسمح
بالوقوف على اسئله ملحه تبحث عن اجابات
شافيه تفسر هذا المشهد الغريب سنسحب في
رحله بحثيه استقصائيه تمكنا خلالها من
الوصول لشخصيات كانت اما جزء من الحدث او
موجوده هناك لحظه وقوعه ضحايا مسؤولون
وعسكريون وشهود عيال
كما تمكنا من الحصول على وثائق سريه كشفت
لنا جزءا من اسرار وكواليس الاحداث
ومعلومات تعرضها الجزيره لاول مره الاسباب
والمعطيات التي انتجت المشهد الحالي
بداناها من هناك من جبال
[موسيقى]
صعده طبعا الحروب السته في تصور انه غيرت
اليمن والى
الابد كانت حرب عبثيه الحروب السته لم تكن
لها معنى على الاطلاق سو التخلص من الفرقه
الاولى مدرع والمنتمين اليه والتخلص ايضا
من القبائل الدكتور الحاضري يحمل رتبه
عميد في الجيش اليمني وشهاده الدكتوراه في
القانون الدولي وكان هناك على مسرح
العمليات العسكريه طوال فتره الحروب
الست وهي تلك الحروب التي جرت بين نظام
علي عبد الله صالح وجماعه الحوثي بدات في
يونيو
2004 وانتهت في فبراير
[موسيقى]
2010 كانت القبيله في تلك الحروب منحازه
الى الجيش ومقاتله معه
لن نسرد هنا قصه الحرب لكننا سنقترح من
بعض التفاصيل التي نعتقد انها ساهمت في
انتاج المشهد الحالي كان اولها تجاهل علي
عبد الله صالح لتحركات الحركه الحوثيه في
مرحله التاسيس وما قبل الحرب الاولى اتضحت
الحقيقه الذي كان هو يتجاهلها اصلا من
التقارير التي كانت ترفع من الاجهزه
الامنيه في صعده ومن ومن قياده المحافظه
ان هذه الحركه حركه بدات يعني تكشر عن
انيابها حركه خطيره حركه لا تنتمي الى
الوطن حركه لا تنتمي الى الواقع حركه يعني
غير المالوف ف كان يتجاهل هذه التقارير
العقيد عسكر زعيل من ابرز الضباط
المشاركين في الحرب وكان احد المقربين من
اللواء علي محسن الاحمر قائد المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه
التي قادت المعارك خلال تلك
الحروب خلال بحثنا حصلنا على تسجيل مصور
نادر للجيش اليمني يظهر سيطرته على جبال
مران في صعده اثناء الحرب الاولى والتي
انتهت بمقتل حسين بدر الدين الحوثي مؤسس
الجماعه يظهر في هذا التسجيل قاده الجيش
اليمني حين ذاك اللواء علي محسن الاحمر
قائد المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه وقائد
الفرقه الاولى مدرع العميد حميد
القشيبي قائد اللواء 310 مدرع العميد ثابت
جواس قائد اللواء 15 مشاه
جواز جواز
ح كادت الحرب ان تحسم بعد هذه
المعركه الا ان هناك من اراد لها ان تستمر
وهنا برز امامنا الكثير من علامات
الاستفهام في الحرب الثالثه تم القضاء على
الحوثيين ايضا ولم يتبقى معهم سوادي اسمها
وادي فله وقد التف عليهم اللواء اللي كان
يقوده عبد العزيز الشاري التف عليهم من
حيدان ووصل الى وادي فله وكان الحوثيون
الذين حصروا في الوادي ولم يتبقى سواهم
كانوا ي كانوا وسطوا وساطه انه نخرج من من
هذا الوادي ونسلم اسلحتنا واتركونا بامان
انتهى كل شيء خلاص يعني في الحرب الثالثه
ق المره الثالثه ليتم القضاء عليها تاتي
اوامر من علي عبد الله صالح بانه انسحبوا
من كل الواقع انسحبوا من صعف انسحبوا
انسحب ايش خلاص الجماعه انتهوا ما عاد فيش
يعني قال انسحبوا وانسحبت القوات فعلا من
اماكن تموضعها وعادت مره اخرى الى مواقعها
وترك الحوثيين وحال سبيلهم حتى يستعدوا
لحرب الرابعه كان اللافت في شهاده الدكتور
الحاضري هو تطابقها مع ما ورد في مقابله
العقيد عسكر رغم عدم علم اي منهما بمقابله
الاخر والفارق الزمني بين المقابلتين
وهو ما تطابق ايضا مع شهاده الشيخ فهد
الشرفي وهو من ابناء صعده واحد قاده
المؤتمر الشعبي العام الحزب الحاكم
انذاك كان الشرف في مقررا لاحدى لجان
الوساطه التي شكلها الرئيس المخلوع علي
عبد الله صالح والتي تراسها فارس مناع وهو
شخصيه مقربه منه عندما نصل الى منطقه فيها
مثلا احد قاده قائد كتيبه الدبابات في
الاول جبلي بعد ان حرر منطقه شاسعه من
الحوثيين ويظهر الخراب والحريق والدمار
وهناك عشرات المدرعات التي احترقت بافعال
الالغام وقد طهر هذه المنطقه وكسر وهزم
الحوثيين ودحرهم ثم ناتي نحن كلجن لن عليك
ان تنزل من كل هذه المواقع التي وصل اليها
جنودك يرفض هذه التوجيهات ف ياخذ فارس
مناع التلفون ويتواصل بعلي عبد الله صالح
ويسلمه لهذا الضابط ليقول له عليك ان تنزل
بسرعه ما عليك الا تنفذ التوجيهات فارس
مننا استمر علي عبد الله صالح بتوجيه
الاوامر مباشره للقيادات الميدانيه
بالانسحاب متجاهلا بذلك القواعد واللوائح
العسكريه
التي تلزمه بعدم تجاوز قاده الجيش
المخولين دستوريا وقانونيا بقياده الحرب
اتت الاوامر الرئاسيه وانا كنت عضوا في
اللجنه الرئاسيه بان يتم سحب ال 17 مشاه
وان يتنازل هؤلاء الشرفاء عن كل تضحياتهم
وان يتركوا حتى جثث زملائهم ولم يوها حتى
ولم يخرمها حتى بالدفن ومما تكشف لنا خلال
البحث ما كان يحدث بين كل حرب واخرى وكيف
اسهم ذلك في تقويه جماعه الحوثي واضعاف
الجبهه المواجهه لهم انا في تصوري كان وقف
اطلاق النار اكبر جريمه ترتكب لانه كان
تباد القبيله وتقتل القبائل الذي وقفوا
معنا والدوله تتفرج عليه يقول والله انا
موقف اطلاق نار مع الحوثي كل هؤلاء قدموا
على طبق من ذهب هناك العديد ايضا من
القبائل التي نزحت وقاتلت مع الدوله ثم
تخلت عن الدوله في وقت الهدن انا اسميها
المصالحات
المهلكات هذا السيناريو وقع الى درجه ان
فقدت القبيله ثقتها
بالدوله انا اقول من هنا بان كل
الانتصارات التي حققها الحوثيين في صعده
كانت انتصارات مصنوعه تاتي بقرارات من
داخل القصور في صنعاء بل احيانا تاتي
التوجيهات بان يسلم الموقع بما فيه من
دبابات ومن اسلحه ويخرج الجند ببزات
العسكريه وربما بسلاح الش اللواء 105
مشاه كان متواجد في مديريه الظاهر في خمس
دبابات في مدفعيه فيه عتاد فيه سلاح فيه
مؤن تكفيه لما يزيد على ست اشهر ويقاتل من
موقع القائد اللواء 105 اعطى اوامر علي
عبد الله صالح له بتسليم اسلحته بالكامل
بالكامل الى الحوثيين والانسحاب باسلحتهم
الشخصيه وهذا كان اول
مكسب اكتسبه الحوثيون كسلاح ثقيل وهذا
قائد اللواء تمت محاكمته هو عسكريا معروف
عندنا وكان يقول انا جاتني في التحقيق انا
جاتني اوامر من علي عبد الله صالح انه
اسلم اسلحتي واسلم اللواء
للحو بعد الحرب الخامسه علي عبد الله صالح
قال لابد ان يذهب الجيش ثم تم نشر قواه
تسمى قوات الامن الامن الخاص وزع في كل
مديريه ما لا يقل عن 20 طقم من اطقم الامن
المركزي مجهزه برشاشات الامن المركزي
يقوده يحيى محمد عبد الله صالح ابن اخ
الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح في ليله
من الليالي تم تلقوا توجيهات من قياده
الامن الخاصه والامن المركزي بان لا
يواجهوا الحوثيين وسلموا الاطقم وسلموا كل
شيء للحوثيين فارس مناع كانت كانت بينه
شراكه كبيره هو علي عبد الله صالح وكان
يقدم كل ما يحتاجه الحوثيين من السلاح
بشكل واضح بشكل واضح كنا نذهب في لجان
الوساطه نزل مره الى غمر وعندها اربع
سيارات محمله بالذخائر ل الحوثيين يحاصروا
بها ابناء غمر وهو رئيس لجنه وساطه كيف
رئيس لجنه وساطه وياتي بمدد للحوثيين هكذا
سلح الحوثيون بسلاح
الدوله واخذت المعركه تنحو منحا اخر وبدات
تتكشف استراتيجيه علي عبد الله صالح في
الحكم التي وصفها هو بالرقص على رؤوس
الثعابين كان هناك اراده ان يتم تعريه
الحدود اليمنيه السعوديه من كل القوات
اليمنيه سواء قوات الجيش او الامن وسحب كل
هذه القطاعات العسكريه ليصبح الحوثيين
وجها الى وجه وجه لوجه مع السعوديه دخول
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بطلب من علي عبد
الله صالح كدوله شرعيه ل يعني حفظ الحدود
وفقا
للاتفاق للاتفاق المعروف اللي هو اتفاق
الدفاع المشترك والحدود على الحدود
وغيرها كانت قصص الحرب تخفي ما وراءها من
خبايا
ومفارقات لكن القصه الاغرب كانت ربما هي
الاكثر كشفا عما يدور في عقل صالح انا
اقول شاهد عليه ولا ولا اقول قال كانت
العمليات هناك عمليات تنسيقيه ما بيننا
وما بين الاخوه الموجودين في غرفه
العمليات المتقدمه مع الاخوه السعوديين
اتصل ليذا
الاخ المنسق ل الطيران في المركز المتقدم
يريد ان يتاكد من الاحداثيات مثل بقيه
الاحداثيات وانا في في المكتب فتاكد ف
تفاجات انا قلت له انت متاكد من الرقم قال
انا متاكد من الاحداثيه ان هذا الرقم هو
الذي جاء قلت له عموما هذه
الاحداثيه هي في منطقتك او في مركز قيادتك
الذي انت متواجد فيه انت واللواء علي محسن
وانت
والمسؤولين احداثيه تمرر من جهاز امن قومي
الى وزاره دفاع جهاز الامن القومي من كان
يسيطر عليها اصلا و علي عبد الله صالح وا
ابن اخيه يعني معروف كان السيناريو الجديد
القادم لعلي عبد الله صالح هو كيفيه
التخلص من الاقوياء الذي يعتقد انهم عقبه
امام حكم التوريث القادم للعائله والفصيله
الواحده هذه القضايا والق التي عشتها يوما
بيوم جعلتني اشعر ان اننا نعيش بلد تحكمه
عصابه
الامام عل انتهت الحروب الست واصبح
الحوثيون بعدها بالاضافه الى كونهم جماعه
دينيه تعتقد بحقها الالهي في الحكم اصبحت
تمتلك من الخبره العسكريه والسلاح ما
يجعلها اكثر قدره على القتال لاستعاده حق
مسلوب حسب
زعمهم واصبح صالح يمتلك ورقه جديده يمكن
ان يلعب بها في الوقت المناسب كان ذلك
ايذانا بعلاقه تمتد لها خيوط عابره لحدود
الزمان والمكان ينسج بهما واقع جديد ليس
على اليمن فحسب بل ربما على المنطقه
[موسيقى]
برمتها ظل الحوثيون شبه محاصرين في صعده
رغم سيطرتهم عليها ولم يكن بامكانهم
الخروج بافكارهم خارج اسوارها الا فيما
ندر جاءت ثوره الشباب السلميه فانتهز
الحوثيون هذه الفرصه واصبح لديهم خيام في
قلب صنعاء فهل كان
الحوثيون اوفياء لهذه الثوره الموت امريكا
الموت
الئ تحبش تعبنا تعبنا
الحريه ما بين الثوره والانقلاب ثوره
الشباب الشعبيه السلميه التي اندلعت في
الحادي عشر من فبراير
2011 الروح
بالدم وانقلاب الحوثيين المسلح الذي جرى
في الحادي من سبتمبر
2014 وقفتنا تفاصيل
كثيره لكن اللافت منها والاكثر تاثيرا هو
ما لم يظهر بالشكل الكافي على وسائل
الاعلام وشكل محطات هامه لها علاقه مباشره
بما يحدث اليوم اعلن الحوثيون وقتها
انضمامهم للثوره بعد ان استكملوا سيطرتهم
على صعده بتنصيب محافظ جديد لها كان على
راس القائمه السوداء ء لتجار ومهربي
السلاح كان هو فارس مناع ذاته الذي تراس
لجنه الوساطه اثناء الحروب الست وادرجت
الامم المتحده وفقا للفقره الثامنه من
القرار
1844 في قائمه الافراد الذين انتهكوا
الحظر على توريد الاسلحه الى جماعه الشباب
المجاهدين في الصومال والذين تربطهم علاقه
بتنظيم القاعده الذي تدعي جماعه الحوث
محاربته كانت هذه احدى المفارقات الغريبه
التي تعكس تناقضا بين شعارات الحوثيين
وممارساتهم لم يقتصر ذلك على تحالفاتهم
وانما امتد الى واقع تحركاتهم على الارض
والذي افرغ شعارهم من
محتواه ففي الوقت الذي كانت تنادي في فيه
بالموت لامريكا واسرائيل كانت تبعث رسائل
الموت والدمار لليمنيين الرافضين
لمشروعها لبيك يا حسين لبيك يا حسين بدات
جماعه الحوثي نشاطها الثوري باق احام
شعاراتها الخاصه التي تتعارض في جوهرها مع
روح فكره الشباب الذين خرجوا ضد كل افكار
الماضي التي اعاقت بناء الدوله في اليمن
لم نتراجع لم نتراجع ل نتراجع وكشا هد على
هذه اللحظه التقينا الناشط الثوري محمد
المقبلي والذي كان من اوائل الشباب الذين
نزلوا الى الميدان واطلقوا الشراره الاولى
للثوره ليس لنا الحق نحن مثلا كشباب ان
نمنع احد من الالتحاق بالثوره او ان نختبر
نوايا او ان نطلق الاحكام
المسبقه لم تتجرا جماعه اخرى على تجاوز
فكره الشباب برفع صور زعيمها في الساحات
ولا شعاراتها الخاصه الا جماعه الحوثي بل
حاولت كل المكونات بما فيها القبيله ان
تتناغم مع فكره الشباب
وتتوازن انصافه الحقيقه كماه كل مكونات
الثوره داخل مشروع الثوره لكن للاسف
الشديد كانت الانعزاليه وعدم تداخل
وتمازج شباب الصمود اللي كان محسوبين على
الحوثي مع شباب الثوره وعدم
تداخل وتبني المفاهيم الجديده التي بدات
تطرح مثل مدنيه الدوله مثل مساله المواطنه
مثل مساله الحريه وكنا نشعر نحن شباب
الثوره ان علينا مسؤوليه بالتواصل معهم
لكن كلما كنا نتواصل مع شبابهم كنا نلاحظ
ان هنالك صد وتخويف من قبل جيرتهم العليا
بعدم الاصغاء للافكار المدنيه الجديده
وكنا نلاحظ ان هنالك سياج من العزله
الذهنيه التي حاولت قياده جماعه الحوثي ان
تفرضها على معظم شبابها الموجودين ضمن
ساحات
الثوره رغم قرار جماعه الحوثي العلني
الانضمام للثوره الا انها اختارت لنفسها
خطا موازيا كان في جوهره يتعارض مع فكره
السلميه حيث استمرت في فتح جبهات القتال
في شمال الشمال ولم يتوقف توسعها العسكري
طوال فتره الثوره وما بعد المبادره
الخليجيه وخلال وبعد مؤتمر الحوار كان في
كل حركه مسلحه او عمليه مسلحه تقوم بها
جماعه الحوثي الجناح المسلح لها في شمال
الشمال سواء في حجور حجه او في اطراف من
محافظه الجوف كان يصاحبها تحرك ميداني
داخل ساحه الثوره من قبل المكونات
الشبابيه المحسوبه على جماعه الحوثي وكما
لو انها كانت تشكل بشكل او
باخر ما يشبه الغطاء المدني للعمليه
المسلحه الي كانت تتم في شمال الشمال الا
بدا الحوثيون توسعهم العسكري خارج صعده
مستغلين انشغال الجميع بما يحدث في ميادين
الثوره تمكنا من توثيق احدى معاركهم في
محافظه حجه رواه لنا عامر والذي ترك قريته
ملتحقا بساحه التغيير بصنعاء وكشف لنا عما
فعله الحوثيون في
قريته بعد مرور اقل من سبعه اش
منذ ان التحقت بساحه التغيير كان الحوثي
يحاصر قريتي كان الحوثي يقتل
اهلي خلاص الذي جابنا الحوثي هجموا علينا
بالليل
بالرصاص
مبر بجليل واحنا شردنا وخفنا باطفالنا
قادر الله يحكم من خرجني من
[موسيقى]
بيت هذه المديريه جاء اليها زوج ابنه حسين
الحوثي ويدعى يوسف المداني صادر مزارع
كثيره واستولى
عليها كانت زراعه الالغام هي الجريمه
الابشع في هذه المعركه فبعد عوده النازحين
الى
منازلهم بدات المعاناه هذه الارقام قتلت
ما يقارب 70 من ابناء المناطق وخصوصا
النازحين الذين فروا من الحرب هذه بعض
اشلاء
احد الشهداء محمد يحيى الد عشي رحمه الله
بسبب انفجار شديد اتذكر واحده من ابشع قصص
الالغام التي حدثت مع مواطن يدعى محمد يحد
عيشي
حيث كان هذا المواطن اراد الدخول الى
الحمام فانفجر احد الالغام احاله الى اشلا
اشلاء لا تستطيع ان تجد تجد يعني قطعه
مكتمله اشلاء في هذه الاثناء جاء الناس ل
لملمت اشلاء هذا الانسان هذا الضحيه في
شال واثناء ما كانوا يلقط اللحم انفجر لقم
ثاني قتل 18 شخص في دقيقه واحده واصاب 25
شخص بجروح بعضهم لازال ما زال معاقا حتى
الان تمكنا من الحصول على التصوير الذي
يوثق للقصه التي رواها لنا عامر
الله
اكبر استمرت استراتيجيه زراعه الالغام
مصاحبه لتحركات
الحوثيين فعلوا ذلك في كل قريه ومدينه
وصلوا
اليها
[موسيقى]
هكذا بدا الحوثيون مسيرتهم بارهاب المجتمع
ووصلت رسالتهم بالفعل قبل
القول من يقف امام مشروعنا سيناله بطشنا
ومن لم يكن معنا فهو هدف مشروع
لنا واستمر التسع العسكري خلال فتره
الثوره بعد توقيع المبادره الخليجيه في
الث3 من نوفمبر
2011 والذي جرى في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض نصت المبادره على موافقه علي عبد
الله صالح على نقل سلطات الرئاسه قانونيا
الى نائبه عبد رب منصور هادي في غضون 30
يوما وتقام الانتخابات رسميا في الحادي
وال من فبراير
2012 مقابل منح صالح الحصانه من الملاحقه
القضائيه له
ولاسرته الا ان الحوثيين لم يوافقوا على
هذه المبادره بحجه انها اعطت الحصانه
للقتله لكن هؤلاء القتله حسب وصفهم اصبحوا
بعد ذلك حلفاء لهم وشكلوا معهم ثوره مضاده
جعلت كل من له علاقه بثوره
2011 عدوا مشتركا لابد من النيل منه ورغم
ذلك فقد وافقوا ان يكونوا جزءا من مؤتمر
الحوار هكذا اختاروا التموقع في منطقه
الرماديه تتيح لهم ممارسه السياسه والحرب
في ان واحد قاطعوا المبادره وفي الوقت
ذاته شاركوا في مؤتمر الحوار الذي يعتبر
اهم
مخرجاتها قبل يوم واحد من انتهاء المؤتمر
كانت معركه دماج قد حسمت لصالحهم باجلاء
سلفي دماج وكلما اقتربنا من النهايه
واتضحت ملاح المستقبل من خلال وثيقه مؤتمر
الحوط الي بدات ضح ملامح المستقبل لبناء
دوله يمنيه حديثه قائمه على اساس التعايش
والمواطنه والشراكه والتوازن الوطني كلما
نلاحظ انهم بداوا يبتعدوا عن مشروع الدوله
الجديده التي كانوا ضمن مكوناتها ووقعوا
عليها ويذهبوا بمنحى اخر بدا يتقارب خطوه
بخطوه مع النظام السابق للاسف الشديد في
هذه اللحظه قرر الحوثيون وصالح الانتصار
لفكره البندقيه على حساب فكره الدوله
المدنيه التي قامت من اجلها
الثوره تمكن الحوثيون بعد ذلك من اسقاط
حاشد وفشلوا في اسقاط ارحب فعادوا الى
عمران التي سقطت بعد تصفيه قائد اللواء
310 العميد حميد
القشيبي من اسباب سقوط حاشد وعمران هو
التحالف بين بعض مشايخ القبائل المواليه
للرئيس مخلوع علي عبد الله صالح وبين
الحوثيين وفي هذا السياق تمكنا من الحصول
على مكالمه جرت بين المخلوع صالح وبين
الشيخ مبخوت المشرقي احد ابرز مشايخ حاشد
ايوه يا شيخ مبخوت مرحبا كيف حالك سيدي
شفت الرجال ايوه شفت وناقشنا وتفاهمنا مع
وضحنا لك كل ما فيسنا واش قال
ق مستعد يبلغ الجهات
دول بس يلا و
حمين
البيت في البيت حقك نعم نعم ق بدي كلام
قنا يدينا بقش يدينا ما حد كلم في
التلفون ق يا رجال اصرف ما في
الجيب ما في الغيب ولا
واحد لا
هو اذا تش صدق امان انه اغنى من الملك عبد
الله
يلا تمكنا من هذا الحديث الذي ما ندر الو
الو
ايع هذا صاحبي من اول الثوره والناس اللي
ما مع يفعل مر علي بعد بكره وحك مع
السلامه علي حميد جليدان المذكور في
المكالمه هو من المشايخ بارزين في قبيله
حاشد منذ هذه اللحظه بدات تحركات الحوثيين
تتناغم اكثر واكثر مع تحركات المخلوع صالح
واصبحت صنعاء هدفا عسكريا متاحه وهنا
تمكنا من توثيق العديد من الوقائع التي
مهدت لاسقاط العاصمه والتي تفسر لنا جزءا
من اسباب
السقوط كانت همدان هي وجهه الحوثيين قبل
اجتياح
صنعاء حدثنا عدنان الجبروني وهو صحفي مهتم
بتغطيه النزاعات المسلحه عن بعض اللقاءات
التي جرت بين وزير الدفاع وبعض مشايخ
قبائل همدان انا حضرت لقاء وزير الدفاع
ورئيس الامن السياسي التقى بقياده القبائل
التي تواجه الحوثيين طلبوا منه الذخيره
سلاح قال لهم بالواضح انه اي واحد يقتل
منكم شهيد الدوله واي دعم تشتيه مني خاطب
شيخ قبالي اسمه خالد الجماعي كان من ابرز
القبائل التي يعني قياده القبائل المواجهه
الحوثيه حاولنا اكثر من مره الوصول للشيخ
خالد الجماعي ولم نتمكن من ذلك بسبب
الاوضاع الامنيه قررنا حينها الاكتفاء
بشهاده عدنان وقبل ايام قليله من موعد
البث نجحت محاولتنا الاخيره في الوصول الى
الشيخ خالد لقيت اتصال من مكتب وزير
الدفاع على انه يخرج
الوزير ونلتقي مع مشايخ حمدان تكلم انه
سيقف مع القبائل وان صنعاء خط احمر ولن
يتركوا الحوثي يصل اليها وما على القبائل
الا ان تقف وقفه رجل واحد مع الدوله
والدوله ستتعلم قاله
احموا القبيله واحموا المنطقه وسان وال
الدوله هكذا بوضوح كان المشاكل ق احنا
سنكم واذا ما بتقاتل الدوله احنا ب ننسحب
نحنا رحنا ان الحوثيين يخرجوا من همدان
كامل وقالوا لابد اذا اشت يخرجوا من همدان
با يخرجوا من همدان والدوله تخرج من
الاماكن الذي فيها منها معسكرات ثابته مثل
الصمع مثل
فريجه فكان وزير الدفاع رده ضعيف جدا لم
يكن هذاك الرد الذي انه يمثل الجيش ويدافع
عن الجيش فقلت لوزير الدفاع قلت الا
تحزق نفسك سوا الى وزاره الدفاع عملوا
موعد في اليوم التالي في مكتب جلال
الرويشان في الامن السياسي والذي جاء يمثل
الحوثيين ابو راس في اللقاء هذا اتصل عبد
الواحد ابو راس لعلي ابو الحاكم ابو علي
الحاكم فقام علي الذفيف دخل دوره المياه
يكلم علي الحاكم دون يعني خشيه ان نسمع ما
يتكلم دقيقه واذا بوزير الدفاع محمد ناصر
يقوم بعده ويدخلوا دوره المياه يغلقوا
الباب ويتكلموا الاثنين يه الذفيف قائد
اللواء العاشر مع قائد اللواء التاسع مع
محمد ناصر يتكلم مع علي
الح انا اشرت الى جلال الرويشان قلنا ايش
يعني انتوا الان بتن الدوله يعني ما قال
استغراب يعني سالت الشيخ الجمعي هل حصلت
تجاوب من من الوزير فيما قالوا لك انه في
دعم انه كذا وانه كذا يعني ايش اللي
اتفقتوا عليه فقلي ما اتفقنا على شي كلها
وعود كذب كان الدور من محمد ناصر انه
يختار اللجان يعني يختار شخصيات اللجان
الوصطه الذي عتكون بيننا وبين الحوثيين
فاختاروا مشائخ معروفين ولائهم لعلي عبد
الله الصالح وكانوا هؤلا هم الاداه الذي
يقربوا الحوثي وحققوا له انتصارات دون
معارف اسقط الحوثيون همدان وفجروا الكثير
من المنازل كان احدها منزل الشيخ الجماعي
نفسه والذي وعده وزير الدفاع وقت
بالدعم واصل الحوثيون طريقهم نحو العاصمه
صنعاء هذه المره تحت مبرر بعض المطالب
السياسيه كانت المفارقه ان احد هذه
المطالب تمثلت في تنفيذ مخرجات مؤتمر
الحوار التي انقلبوا
عليها استمر حصارهم لصنعاء شهرا كاملا حتى
قرروا اجتياحها خلال الفتره من السادس عش
الى الحادي من سبتمبر من عام
2014 خلال تتبعنا لتفاصيل ما حدث قبل سقوط
صنعاء كانت اخر قصه توقفنا عندها هي قصه
المقاتل الاخير العميد صادق مكرم كان
قائدا للواء الدفاع الجوي ومن الذين
قاتلوا الحوثيين في الحروب السته في
السابق وكان من ابطال الفرقه الاولى مدرع
شاب كان قائد لواء الدفاع الجوي وكان انا
من انبى الرجاله اليمن على الاطلاق يمكن
ان تقول انه يكاد يساوي اللواء حميد
القشيبي رحمه الله لولا الفارق الزمني
وحجم الرصيد التاريخي فقط خرج في مهمه
عسكريه من وزاره مكلف بها من وزاره الدفاع
بناء على امر عملياته على اساس ان يصل من
رئاسه الفرق الدرع من شملان في مذبح وان
يتج الى فوق وادي ظهر حتى يحجم قوات
الحوثيين التي وصلت الى
الوادي حصلت الجزيره على وثيقه التي تثبت
تكليف العميد صادق مكرم من قبل وزاره
الدفاع وقياده المنطقه السادسه في سياق
بحثنا عن تفاصيل قصه العميد صادق مكرم
تمكنا من الوصول للمرافق الشخصي الذي كان
شاهدا على اللحظات الاخيره في حياته قاللك
اخرج الى منطقه شملان حزم امني عن صنعا
تواصل الافندم صادق مع الحاوري قال الخدمه
امن نمشي وانا بقول يا فندم هم بينتشر حول
عماير بينتشر مجهز لنا بكما بقول يا فندم
قدامنا كمين حنا كنا اخر الكم يعني بعد
التلفون الجهاز السلكي قد بتواصل معه قاد
المنطقه الحوري بتواصل معه وزير الدفاع
بتواصل ولا حد قالوا التعزيز جايه التعزيز
معان جرحه بيموت وهك يعني بدون يعني لا
اسعافات لا حاجه لا وبتواصل معهم ضبح
الفند مسك الجهاز الا سلكي وزقله زقل حتى
كل حاجه احنا احنا وم ل جعت الرصاص علينا
واحنا احنا وال الفندم وهو بيقاتل جنبنا
انا جرحت
قبله انا جرحت طلقا في راسي قبل الفندم صق
تخيل الفندم اقسم بالله العظيم انه جلس
يناز لساعه تس في الليل يوم استشهد العميد
صادق مكرم ادركت ان الفرقه الادرع سقطت
واننا اصبحنا في حقب الاموات فقد ننتظر
رصاصه الرحمه يقع معسكر الفرقه الاولى
مدرع سابقا المسمى حاليا قياده المنطقه
السادسه في قلب العاصمه صنعاء كان من
اوائل الاهداف العسكريه لجماعه الحوثي
الكمين اللي قتل فيه صادق مكرم رحمه الله
كان لا يبعد عن بوابه رئاسه الفرقه حوالي
6 ك متر
فقط الصحفي عدنان كان متابعا لما جرى وكان
هناك على مسرح الاحداث في اليوم الثاني
لواق مقتل العميد صادق مكرم خرجت مع الناس
الى عند الجثث
وجدت ناس كثير مواطنين كثير خرجوا من رعب
الليله السابقه وهول الاشتباكات خرج الناس
كلهم في الصبح يشاهدوا ما الذي حدث انا
وصلت الى عند الجثت وفي ناس كثير محلقين
حتى بعضهم كان ياخذ الشال الذي على كتف
يغطي بها جثه جندي احكم الحوثيون قبضتهم
على المنطقه لم تكن تحت سيطرتهم اصبحت
المنطقه جزء من العاصمه صنعاء وكانت اول
سيطره للحوثيين في العاصمه صنعاء كان عبد
الخالق الحوثي الشقيق عبد الملك الحوثي هو
منقاد تلك
المعركه وكان في نقاط للجيش فاول ما اقترب
الحوثيون من المنطقه وشاهدوه الجنود
باعينهم قال في مساعد هناك اعتقد اسمه
العواضي قال لهم يلا يلا احنا بنعطف ونرجع
المعسكر العمليات فانا قربت منه وسالته
ليش تنسحب الناس جنبكم قاوموا في شباب
كثير بقاتل طالع فوق وكذا انتم الجيش ليش
تنسحب والناس هولا يقاتلوا قي هكذا بوضوح
عندنا اوامر من المنطقه وقياده العمليات
انه ننسحب وخلي الاصلاحيين يحلوا مشكلتهم
مع الحوثيين فعلا انسحب الجيش وانا اشاهد
حتى الويه الحرس الجمهوريه التي كانت دخل
الحوثي الى العاصمه صنعاء من جوار لوائين
لواء للدفاع الجوي ولواء للحرس الجمهوري
اللي كان يسمى من سابق معسكر الاستقبال
هذه الالويه لم تحرك ساكن فضلا عن انها لم
تختبر في مواجهه الحوثيين كانت الوحدات
العسكريه التي يتحدث عنها عدنان تتبع
الحرس الجمهوري الذي ظل مواليا للرئيس
صالح حتى بعد تسليمه للسلطه وكانت تتبع
رسميا لوزير الدفاع
انذاك كان هناك شيء غامض حدث للجيش متمثل
في في قياده وزاره الدفاع محمد ناصر احمد
وزير الدفاع هذا هو الصندوق الاسود واللغز
الاكبر كان الرجل انا حضرت مواقف مع مع
الرجل يعني
شاهدت تناقضه يعني الرجل كان متناقض كان
هناك قوه كبيره ممكن انها تواجه الحوثيين
لكنها لم تفعل ولم تفعل ايضا الخلاصه انه
الاخ وزير الدفاع هو الذي اشرف على تسليم
صنعاء سواء باوامر من علي عبد الله صالح
او بمبادره شخصيه
من وزير الدفاع بنفسه في تصوري خان اليمن
خان الامه خان شرفه العسكري خان الامه
العربيه لانه بنفسه اشرف على تسليم صنعاء
بدلا من ان يشرف كواجب وطني ودستوري على
الدفاع عن صنعاء وهذا امر بديهي عندما
يكون وزير الدفاع بنفسه هو الذي يخون
الامه فماذا تتوقع ما الذي يمكن ان يحصل
بعد حادثه شملان قام الرئيس هادي بتكليف
اللواء علي محسن الاحمر بالصعود الى معسكر
الفرقه الاولى مدرع مواجهه
الحوثيين علمنا وقتها ان الدكتور الحاضري
كان شاهدا على تلك اللحظات الاخيره فعدنا
اليه وقابلناه مره اخرى ليروي لنا
التفاصيل كنت في منزل الو علي
محسن جا اتصال تليفوني من الرئاسه عند عبد
الرب منصور هذا كان على الخط واخبر اللواء
علي محسن ان يصعد الى الفرقه الاولى مدرع
ويدير معركه الدفاع عنها وضع سماعه
التليفون واخبر لعلي محسن قال اطلع يا عبد
الله اللي هو كان يحدثني انا اسبق ال
الفرقه واخبر بوابه الامن اني صعدت من
البوابه الجنوبيه وصل الوعي محسن لكن
حقيقه انا عندما وصلنا الى الفرقا لم نجد
كتائب لم نجد وحدات عسكريه وفي نفس الوقت
كل وحدات الحرس الجمهوري كانت تضرب كان
المدفع من الذين عندما يضرب قذيفه واحده
كان يضرب بشره وينتهي الطاقم باكمله يعني
انتهى تقريبا طاقه كان فوق مدفع 2 او اطلق
طلقتين فقط وضرب بقذيفه مباشره انتهى كل
الطاقم موجودين لم يكن يسمح لنا حتى ان
نرفع رؤوسنا على الاطلاق كان محكوم علينا
بالموت الجميع بلا استثناء في اليوم
الثالث ال 21 الى الساعه الحاد ع ظهرا
ونحن ما زلنا داخل الفرقه الامتع كان الو
علي محسن بنفسه برشاش متنقل من مكان الى
اخر لكن في تصوري كان كل شيء المساله قد
حسمت والتطويق التم ولم يتبقى شيء سوى سوى
رصاصات الموت خرج و علي محسن المعسكر
الساعه 11 ظهرا قلنا انه سيوف على المواقع
لكن كانت الفرقه قد حاصرت من كل اتجاهات
وكنا نقول ان خروج ايضا مغامره في حد
ذاتها
خرج ولم يعد على الاطلاق انتظرت تقريبا
فتره خرجت من المكان الذي انا فيه قالوا
اختراق من البوابه الغربيه من البوابه
الشرقيه خرجت اريد ان اثب البوابه الغربيه
لم اجد احدا كانما خرجتنا على اثر هجوم
نووي لم اجد في حتى انسان كان الكل قد صحب
من الفرقه الاولى مدرع خرجت بعد ذلك كنت
اريد ان احرق اتلف كان في عندي وثائق
وارشيف المعسكر لكني ما استطعت حتى ان
ادخل الى المكتب كان القصب شديد
وقلت يعني المساله خلاص يعني ماد بقش مجال
الواحد يخشى على نفسي ما كن اخشى بقدر ما
كنت اخشى ان ابقى على قيد الحياه فيتم
مسكي وانا حي مصيبه كانت كارثه فال خرجت
بعد ذلك وانا مش متوقع ان اخرج على قطح
وصلت الى البوابه التي لد وزاره الاعلام
خرجت من البوابه
الشرقيه فرض الحوثيون سيطرتهم على
صنعاء كانت قبائل ارحب هي المهدده الابرز
لاستمرار السيطره على العاصمه ومواصله
الانتشار في بقيه
المحافظات بالذات وان هذه القبائل هي التي
انهزم الحوثيون امامها في بدايه
2014 اثناء المحا الاولى للاقتراب من
صنعاء وتمكنت القبائل حينها من صدهم وهي
ذاتها التي وقفت في وجه صالح خلال الثوره
2011 عاد الحوثيون الى ارحب وكانت
الكاميرا حاضره لتوثق ما جرى من خلال
شهادات
اهلها يا
ساتر يا ساتر الله اكبر الله يجعلها في
نحوركم يا عباء الله الله اكبر الله
يجعلها في نحوركم يا كلاب حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل حسبنا الله ونعم
[موسيقى]
الوكيل مجرد في بيوتنا ثلاث عائله خير من
النزل من الرجال الله يفتح عليهم جو اخذوا
ولدي من جنب جنب مسكن
بيتي اخذوه
وساروا به
مادرنا انخطفو حتى الان اليوم تسير واحنا
بلاق
بعده اخرجونا بيوتنا شردونا وشردوا
اطفالنا بيتنا الذي قد لنا سنين بنبنيه
ذحين الان
[موسيقى]
فجروه استمرت استراتيجيه ترويع المجتمع
وواصل الحوثيون ومعهم مليشيات صالح
التعريف بانفسهم من خلال تحركاتهم على
الارض صرخت افعالهم في وجه المواطن اليمني
مخيره اياه اما ان تخضع لنا او فانك داعشي
تستحق القتل فقد اطلق الحوثيون وصف
الداعشي على كل من يختلف معهم
لم تتوقف هذه الاستراتيجيه على مكونات
المجتمع فحاسب بل امتدت الى اعلى هرم
السلطه فبعد سقوط صنعاء تتابعت الاحداث
حتى اصبح الرئيس هادي مستهدفا من قبل
جماعه الحوثي والرئيس المخلوع علي عبد
الله صالح استطاع بعد ذلك الخروج الى عدن
وتمت ملاحقته وقصف قصر المعاش
الذي اقام فيه ادرك الحوثيون ومعهم صالح
ان اسقاط هادي ضروره لاتمام
الانقلاب قرر هادي الخروج من عدن باتجاه
المكله وقبل ان يغادر البلد عبر عمان كانت
المحاوله الاخيره لاغتياله قرت بنفسي الى
نقطه بروم وجدنا الرئيس هناك واقف في
النقطه معه تقريبا 20 سياره خمس صوال
15 اتصلت بالعمليه قلنا لهم ابلغوا النقاط
وعمم 20 السياره اللي جان البلاغ فيها هذه
قائد المنطقه العسكريه مع مشايخ شبوه قصدي
نحاول نمشي الرئيس احنا محافظين على
الشرعيه وعلى امور كثيره كان يشتي يمر
القصر يرقد نا هنا قلنا الوضع ما يسمحش
بالمرور المكل يعني عندنا القوات الخاصه
عندنا الامن الامن الخاص عندنا بعض
الوحدات
تمام الحرس الجمهوري تواصل
معي ياسر
العواوي لمحلي على الموضوع انه الرئيس ما
عندنا عل
بعد علي عبد الله صالح يقول عندكم الرئيس
هذا
اعتقلوه ما فيش عندنا احد من قال اعتقلوه
هذا مع ملايين الدولارات وشله صوالي
المدرعه و قنا قد خربتوا عدن وصنعاء اكفي
المكل اذا اجانا يخرج له بر ولا جو ولا
بحر ما فيش داعي يبقى المكلا احنا قصدي
نهد الامور
و قال خلاص لا يبقى قلنا لا
يبقى كان يشتد في الكلام ويقاطع الكلام ما
يلقيك يتكلم ويواصل علي عبد الله صالح
محاولته المستميته بل ويوجه بقصف القصر
الجمهوري في المكله اذا كان هادي متواجدا
فيه حاول اتاكد مره
ثانيه تاكد ماهوش موجود ماهوش في القصر
الجمهوري ارشق القصر الجمهوري واصلت جماعه
الحوث الانتشار وفرض السيطره على ما
استطاعت الوصول اليه من محافظات اليمن بدا
الامر للجميع ان جماعه الحوثي تبنت
الاستراتيجيه القتاليه بفعل الحروب الست
وما اصبح يعرف بمظلوم
صعده لكن ما حصلنا عليه من الوثائق كشف
لنا امرا اخر
احدى هذه الوثائق هي عباره عن خطه عمل
متكامله وضعتها جماعه الحوثي للسيطره على
محافظه اب وما يثير
الاستغراب انها تبعد عن صعد اكثر من 400
كيل
متر اعد هذه الخطه من اسمته الوثيقه ب 17
مجاهدا تكشف الخطه عده نقاط تساعدنا في
فهم عقليه الجماعه وكيف
تفكر تقسم الوثيقه العمل الى عده مجالات
احدها العمل الجهادي حسب وصفها وهو ما
يؤكد ان الجماعه اختارت العمل المسلح
خيارا استراتيجيا وليس كوسيله للدفاع عن
النفس كما لفت
انتباهنا ان العمل في بعض الم يات بدا قبل
الحرب الاولى وهو ما يشكك بفرض ان
الحوثيين تبنوا استراتيجيه التوسع
الجغرافي بعد الحروب الست اما الاهم فكان
تاريخ اعداد هذا الملف والذي يوافق ال 15
من مارس
2013 اي قبل انطلاق مؤتمر الحوار بثلاثه
ايام وهو ما يثبت ان الحوثيين دخلوا مؤتمر
الحوار وهم يبيتون امرا اخر لا علاقه له
بالحوار تكشف الوثيقه عن منهجيه الحركه
الحوثيه لسكره المجتمع وتحويل المواطنين
الى مجندين يقاتلون في سبيل ما اسموه
بالميره
القرانيه وهو الاسم الذي تستخدمه جماعه
الحوثي في عمليه الحشد لم يتوقف ما اسموه
بالعمل الجهادي خلال الحروب الست وخلال
الثوره وما بعد ذلك بل وصل الامر الى
اختراق الاجهزه الامنيه للدوله من خلال
حصر المناطق التي ينتمي افرادها لاجهزه
المخابرات والتوجيه بالحذر منهم ومحاوله
[موسيقى]
اختراقهم على المستوى الثقافي لم تجد
الجماعه حرجا في اقحام العمليه التعليميه
في معركتها بل وتسويق فكرتها
للطلاب هكذا جعلت جماعه الحوث تفخيخ
المجتمع الاستراتيجيه الاساسيه لتحقيق
اهدافها في نهايه بحثنا كان واضحا كيف كيف
استطاعت جماعه الحوثي من خلال استغلال
طريقه الحكم التي مارسها الرئيس المخلوع
علي عبد الله صالح طوال 33 عاما ومن خلال
ارهاب المجتمع واظهار مدى استعدادها للبطش
والقتل والتفجير ان تروض المجتمع ولو
لفتره مؤقته واتضح لنا كيف استغلت الجماعه
ثوره الشباب السلمي
ولم تجد حرجا بعد ذلك من التحالف مع من
قامت ضده الثوره وان تبنيها لفكره السلاح
والحرب لم يكن للدفاع عن النفس وانما جزء
من مشروع يسعى للوصول الى الحكم اما صالح
فلم يجد حليفا يمكنه من الانتقام الا
جماعه
الحوثي تحالف شكل ثوره مضا
كانت هي العامله الابرز في انتاج المشهد
الحالي مشهد بد للبعض انه تشكل في السنوات
الاخيره لكن ما ثبت لدينا ان ما يحدث
اليوم هو امتداد
لمخطط بدا منذ عقود من
[موسيقى]
الزمن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ا